hey youtubers is Charlie there's only
one more episode left in Walking Dead
this season we finally got a good look
at terminus and we got a big reunion
that we've been hoping for for a while
there's still a bunch of huge questions
though mostly who's going to be dying
next week it was really nice that we did
get to see most of the survivors but
what I'm gonna do is my top five moments
and then some of the biggest questions
that we have before next week with some
potential answers to those quick shout
up for my giveaway if you're a friend of
me for the first time I give away an
Amazon gift card to a random subscriber
in the comments on all these review
videos just as a way to say thank you to
all you guys for being awesome
all you have to do is be subscriber and
leave a comment to enter but I'm gonna
announce who the winner is tomorrow in
The Walking Dead Q&A video for this
episode so let's talk some terminus
careful for potential spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet but number
five outdoor cat Daryl Joe seemed
unusually cogent while he was explaining
his brave new world to Daryl I love that
he just dropped cat facts Daryl never
did answer as to whether or not he was
the cat person but the speech was just
Joe telling Daryl that he was an outdoor
cat just like them like their band of
marauders is the alternative to the more
domesticated survivors who I guess we
can think of as indoor cats
unless you count me shown no amount of
play time with Carl and candy sharing is
gonna make her an indoor cat the writers
are just teasing that Daryl might
seriously decide to split with the
survivors and start running with Joe's
group full-time which we totally do not
want Joe himself after you know all
these Wolfpack Justice moments seems
pretty legit though he's not a cannibal
so I think we can assume that if there
are going to be hunters then they're
gonna be the people that live at the
terminus I'll talk more about that in
just a little bit the real thing we need
to worry about with their group though
is how Daryl's going to react whenever
Joe finds Rick that last moment with the
candy wrapper let us know that Tony you
know that dude who was strangled for the
bed totally saw him we can really call
this one of the giant red flag candy
wrappers for next week number 4
Glenn finds Maggie sign this was such a
fun high point to start the episode off
on you could almost tell what it was
just from the look on his face you know
before they ever reveal the map
as inspected he totally took off like a
crazy person to catch up with her his
commitment to people is just borderline
nuts and I definitely think someday it's
gonna get him killed but since this
happens so early in the episode you know
I wasn't expecting things to get awful
until they approach that tunnel of death
there's just something so awesome about
the imagery of that mouth of the tunnel
like they were stepping into a walkers
open mouth we got to know Glenn so well
over the years that I don't think this
could have gone down any other way
though until he was reunited with Maggie
he was in Robo Glen mode which kind of
makes him a dick in that he's forcing
Tara to injure herself more by following
I think if anyone actually has a chance
to martyr themselves this season it'll
be Tara she just wants to punish herself
so bad I'll talk more about it later but
if she really wanted to punish herself
she'd get involved with another
girlfriend this is a really important
idea being involved in a committed
relationship on Walking Dead is an
absolute death sentence number three
Glenn and Tara in the tunnel of death I
liked how as they move deeper into the
tunnel they move deeper into their awful
memories you know Glenn and his time
right after he was separated from his
family and Tara during the prison battle
did you notice how she always calls the
governor Brian it's just because she
never knew him as the governor it's just
funny because we've known him as this
other persona for so long then running
into that Walker pile-up was a lot of
fun but I think it was just meant to
imply that they had taken the wrong path
if they'd gone the other way the long
way around they still would have found
that car with Abraham and still would
have run into Maggie
because remember Abraham ran into Maggie
before Maggie ran into Glenn supposedly
there was a huge Walker tribute in this
episode and I think it was a Ray
Harryhausen tribute with this
stop-motion lookin Walker
you know we saw from behind let me know
if you think it was a different one I
kept trying to look at other Walker
faces in that tunnel whatever they were
in close up just to see if I recognized
one number two Glenn Maggie's machine
gun reunion how appropriate that it
happened to the sweet music of gunfire
they're both sufficiently crazy so you
couldn't get them back together in
anything less than a [ __ ] crazy
situation I also kind of wrapped
together this WTF moment as being part
of the terror trying to get Glenda bail
on her
remember she definitely wants to martyr
herself but it did feel kind of hollow
because Glenn has proven himself to be
the most stubborn person on the show you
know next to Maggie I don't think he
would ever give up on someone maybe if
he was forced to choose between Maggie
and someone else that would really be an
interesting situation after the reunion
I feel like we needed to rename the
tunnel of death to the tunnel of love or
the tunnel of loving death speaking of
which remember earlier when I said being
in a loving relationship is like a
recipe for disaster
what I meant was is that almost all of
these sex pairs have had someone died on
the show for instance Laurie and Lilly
both slept with the governor they're all
dead all of best boyfriends are dead
Laurie slept with Shane and she's dead
too this means that Abraham Rosita Sasha
Bob Glenn and Maggie are all on my most
likely to die list Maggie is still my
number one pick though in a reversal of
Cannon and my number one moment
Glenn and Maggie's group reaches
terminus it totally looks like it was
full of indoor cats it really does look
like a more flowery version of the
prison but there was that mystery grill
that makes me think that in the finale
they're gonna be revealed as the hunters
and it will be people meat on that grill
we should just call it right now
regardless of what's happening there
terminus is a Venus flytrap it is
totally going to be shutting its jaws on
a few people in the finale the big
questions right now are who are these
people at the terminus you know are they
hunters what is the real lie of terminus
I'm convinced that there's gonna be a
huge reveal you know hunters or not we
still haven't met that new gareth
character the other questions being you
know what happened to Beth and what will
Joe's group do to Rick whenever they
catch up to him we also have to think
about that new person we met Mary that's
Denise Crosby if he didn't recognize her
she doesn't conform exactly to anyone
specifically in the comic books but she
could be that female hunter but in order
for that to work out the show would have
to change a bunch of stuff I just feel
like that grill she was standing in
front of it just so ominous it looks
like that scene from the comics you know
with the hunters at their home base even
though that was a very small group of
people and the setting was very
different as for Beth I don't really
have any evidence to support it
but part of me feels like she's still
alive at terminus somewhere I feel like
we're gonna end up with a situation
where Joe's group will make a move on
Rick and everyone will just be too busy
to notice the evil terminus people
trying to kill everyone now it's your
turn though let me know what was your
favorite moment from the episode and
what is your biggest question before the
finale next week don't forget there's
still the wild-card of Carol and Tyreese
they're two very badass people I feel
like even though they have Judith with
them they're not any less formidable can
you just see them hiking Judith back and
forth to one another like a football
while they kill walkers but I'm really
hoping to see in the finale though is
this darkest moment situation where
things just get awful and then Tyreese
suddenly comes barreling through a wall
like the Hulk and just smashes Joe and
any potential terminus hunter characters
so much stuff is happening [ __ ] hits the
fan next week so get really excited like
I said I'm posting that Q&A video
tomorrow while I'll announce this week's
giveaway winner be sure to subscribe to
get that and leave a comment if you want
to enter the giveaway you can click here
to watch that video I'll add the
annotation as soon as I post it and you
can click here to catch up on last
week's mega WTF episode seriously I'm
getting really excited it's been getting
better every single week thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives